hey everyone welcome back to the swish
Woodland podcast which is of course
proudly brought to you by our major
sponsor swish who give you the
opportunity as a sports lover to get
your very own personalized video message
from your favorite sports star it is
super easy to use the costs range from
300 down to 20 but the beauty of all
that is that up to 70 of the proceeds go
to Kiwi kids Charities which is pretty
special to order head over to
heyswish.com or follow the link below in
the description and don't forget to
enter the code what a lad at the
checkout for 15 off this is a purchase
that you will have no regrets about so
go get amongst it also many of you will
know pure sport have launched right here
in New Zealand for all their non-cbd
products where they have a wide range of
nootropics which is full of the best
stuff you can give your body if you
listen to the grace and heart episode
recently you would have heard about some
of the ingredients involved and how
powerful some of these supplements are
and just how important is to get off
these prescriptions drugs such as
Tramadol to order head over to
puresport.com or follow the link below
and you can also get 20 off this by
using the code water layer20 lastly
grateful to have New Zealand's favorite
horse trainer Regan Todd from Todd's
racing back on board and he is currently
training future New Zealand Cup winner
what a lad if you enjoy your horse
racing you're Keen to get involved in
this there's about five shares left at
1K each they have no ongoing fees and
hopefully we have some absolutely
Priceless times on track winding home
the great what a lad if you're
interested flick me a message and I'll
get the details sent out to you as
always super grateful for the sponsors
to help bring these episodes to you if
you enjoy the podcast go support them
but really appreciate your support enjoy
this episode
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh what I led well another treat for you
today was a lead like many young talents
was labeled the next big thing after
school after captaining the New Zealand
School side but also like many rugby
took him on an incredible roller coaster
with highs which show and play
professionally for the turbos and Bayer
plenty and some lows which included some
serious injuries including concussion
which ended his career in his early
twenties he has been through plenty
since and I'm looking forward to hearing
more about it he is the legendary lad it
is Papa fatawira welcome brother
yeah he takes on the new one
uh thank you for having me here today
brother mate thanks for reaching out and
uh being Keen to come on always helps me
getting gas when guys are Keen to come
on so it has been a while since we
crossed paths briefly at the canes but
mate you're looking good fresh mokel too
love that
yeah yeah you know I look probably
that's probably the only change yeah oh
actually I tell a lie there's a lot done
that happened since then I think it was
back in 2012 2013 yeah I was probably
when we last spent some a bit of time
together
um yes good bro
um my family's healthy I'm healthy
um and things are coming along really
nice for us that's awesome and you've
been retired for what seven years now
that's crazy yeah so how do you look
back at your rugby career
now 2015 will end of 2015 was when I
decided to
um uh close that chapter
um reflecting on it or just the other
day I was in the garage cleaning
everything else and I stumbled across
some old news newspaper articles some
old photos there was a sort of a trip
down memory lane yeah and uh quite
recently my wife and I in Wellington so
we actually went back to where we stayed
during that time uh on Plymouth steps
and so um was good to acknowledge that
that part of our lives back then so did
you look back on your rugby career with
any regrets or things you sort of wish
you did differently or how do you sort
of feel about the whole thing
um yeah yeah for sure bro there's
there's probably a few few moments or
parts within my career as a rugby player
uh where I know things probably could
have played out differently here
um you know my attitude
being a little bit different
um I I guess everything happens for a
reason or I know everything happens for
a reason and I'm quite content knowing
that I did the best that I could with
the tools and knowledge that I had um at
that time
um but I I do is kind of like the stall
it uh this little Ember burning what's
inside me saying you know what if you
had a go now and the current mindset
that you're in yeah
um but yeah I I guess there was always
this um that longing to make our honors
but um yeah I'm I'm very blessed of
where we are now and um all I can I
guess say uh looking back on that prayer
was that I'm really grateful and
fortunate to have all the experiences
make new friends
um in the lifelong friendships that have
come from that so yeah mate that's so
cool a little Ember too mate how good
would it to see you dick out there with
the turbos one day
oh yeah I had the local Club down here
the boys who came to get me on so this
would be a bit of a coach here at um the
Edo Victory club but uh we all know what
that means and I would rather play it
India coaches
yeah here there but mate I'm pretty Keen
to get to your Journeys like obviously
it's pretty cool rugby Journey a little
bit different to a lot of the guys I've
had on but I know there'll be a lot of
lessons in it for people listening so
pretty Keen to start at the start like
always where'd you grow up uh born and
bred in the sunshine capital of
whakatane uh attended and then moved on
to uh Pakistani intermediate uh there's
where the journey began for my Rugby
career started as a little busy boy 12
year old with the snotty nose playing
soccer my whole life
and then uh actually I was forced to
play rugby but an uncle of Monday was my
teacher at intermediate
and um collectors came around and uh I
selected horse riding because I I just
wanted to be a Melbourne cup jockey so
it sounds like my ultimate goal yeah and
he said uh he looked at me screwed up
the paper and he said no boy you're
playing fire Metro and threw it away and
I cried and ran out
yeah so that was kind of like my entry
to ranking and um I'll never forget the
feeling
um when I had ball in hand and kind of
bumped someone over and I just thought
wow this feeling is amazing so um yeah
that's kind of where it all started
where did you love for um horse racing
come from was that from a young fella
because I was the same one of my dreams
was to be a jockey and win the Melbourne
cup as well so that's crazy to hear that
that was yours as well before you went
into rugby yeah bro growing up we're
like
um of before whakatane started
developing especially in the commercial
area
um it was just surrounded in horses
paddocks there at mountains so that was
our playground yeah
um you know and would always try and
throw a leg over a horse and it's not in
that way either just um you know you
have a bit of a bit of fun but yeah I
was 49 kilo dripping wet yeah
um so I had the perfect statue of a
jockey you know um I'm all what five
foot something yeah so I don't know I
think there could have been a real real
exciting life but um hey it wasn't for
me is there a burning Amber there to uh
give that a crack oh my wife and I said
my wife she's actually born in the other
horse uh I'm a Chinese zodiac and and
she she grew up with horses so uh we
hope to implement their backwards in our
lives one day soon that's exciting might
see
um riding home that Melbourne Cup winner
in a few years
uh might be a few horsepower starters
first but uh I'll stay in my Lane to say
I'm a I'm a recreational Rider
yeah but back to your footy Journey so
you're um you're pretty good from a
young age were you as soon as you pretty
much picked up that ball oh I just um I
guess for me like knowing now what it
was it was more of a relief uh I guess
that feeling of you know you know the
feeling when you just bump someone off
not really but it feels so good
well you're probably on the other hand I
was on the other hand too you're the one
being bunted but um
yeah looking back on the Braille was
like a release for me you know all the
frustration the anger um resent
um all of those emotions that were that
I couldn't release at the time
um was was put through
um rugby through code
um you know uh anyone will tell you that
I was quite a bit of a a quite a
physical aspect
um I like the getting into those dark
spaces I like throwing girls punch here
and there you know because I could get
away with it yeah without going through
the court of law as as you progress on
into professional rugby the camera is on
you and you can't can't quite do that
anymore so
um yeah that was a massive release for
me so where was all we was all the anger
coming from as a young fella did you
was it from upbringing or did you just
you're just an aggressive person yeah
yeah all of that both
um now kind of where we are now we you
know we have to do a lot of that inner
work to find out what that actually was
yeah
um and a lot of it was you know like
um physical abuse sexual abuse
uh mental abuse emotional abuse you know
throughout your whole lifetime bro
um and all of that if it's not if it's
not released it actually stores within
your body you know there's nowhere for
it to go so you can think of a Time
yourself where you want it to cry you're
one of the to smack someone in the face
all of those things in your commit
you've had to hold it back
um you know because because it's got
nowhere to go it's got nowhere else to
go but in your body so it becomes a part
of Who You Are
yeah that's not only um until recently
that I've been able to dive into those
depths of my subconscious where it's
being forgotten
um and kind of go back to those memories
or times in my life where I've had to
um accept it acknowledge it feel it
release it Let It Go from me because it
doesn't serve me and you make a choice
what to replace that with yeah I love
that so rugby was like your real release
uh that's sort of why you loved it so
much you get out there like you said let
off some anger
um I guess release all these emotions
and then obviously you're good at it too
so it became a bit of a cycle yeah
absolutely and all the boys love it when
the gears come around too
but that's always a fun part of rugby
um but just yeah I guess the comrade
shop as well
um being a part of so many different
things uh the journey itself you know
winning's always a big part of it too
um for celebrating uh being in good
company and just being a part of the
team environment that's that's kind of
what I like to do so did you move to
Rotorua just to play rugby because
obviously it's a pretty well known
Factory for producing pretty high
quality rugby players was that why you
moved there uh yeah well uh Mark
actually wanted me to get a couple
folder oh yeah and um another Uncle
mine's definitely said no boys no
opportunity there it'll just be a toilet
seat warmer so he said uh lots of boys
in um as a 12 year old I made that
decision
um to go to the hostel yeah um yeah
I love my parents were lucky enough to
be in a position to support my desire to
essential to our boys and um that's been
all shipped off but yeah that's been
probably two three years on the hostel I
think when I was fourth form I ended up
going over to England uh over in
Cornwall and like City culturo
uh and just go there for about three or
four months uh that was rugby as well
um had a little bit of involvement with
the the fan arts Club over there
um a little 14 year old bumping over
grown men true and then I've got to see
the Cornish Pirates play over there so
it was um yeah really cool
so what we what are we playing like um
Club rugby at 14. I was playing score
rugby yeah
um but then I'd go to the premiere club
rugby training and just um get stuck in
there yeah it was good good fun bro no
you must have been unreal to be able to
even think about competing with grown
men at 14. yeah well I guess that's been
me with my whole life because I've been
you know I'm only a small fella
um I've always had to try and I guess
prove myself you know keep up with the
big boys and and away so yeah that's
that's only just brought out the best of
me really
um when I when I looked back on it so
your last year at school
um obviously must have been pretty
successful because you did end up like I
mentioned in the intro captaining the
New Zealand School side which is a
massive achievement and once you've got
that tag
um you get opportunities come to you
pretty quickly so what was that last
year of school like for you oh yeah that
last year was really um yeah it was
really a full-on uh we had we had made
it I think we beat Tauranga boys in the
playoffs and it was eight seven
um and they they had the best four pack
in the country they had semi Kane on the
open side there Tikes and that number
eight in uh a guy George stork their
Blind Side and yeah she was gone for May
7 to go to the top four
and of course lost Hamilton boys
but yeah yeah we are made for NZ under
17's team as well that year and also
that was when they introduced the uh the
Chiefs schools
um and then I guess where there was by
luck or by chance
um car accidents was our captain for
schools and he he felt a pretty horrific
injury uh in one of our
games against the water Tour on the 19
Squad
um and then the coaching staff at the
time thought that it would be best for
me to take over
um we felt that loss like something
crazy because Carl was a Carl is an
amazing player and the leadership
qualities that he has was just you know
top of the line did you feel comfortable
stepping in as Captain once you get that
tag did you feel confident to do it uh
well I actually didn't
um I I just wanted to be a part of the
boys and I always have been and looking
back you know always always been put in
um situations where the Limelight was on
me or roles of leadership and I never
really wanted it at the time
um although I accepted it it was kind of
like I yeah I wasn't quite ready to to
step up well I just wanted to be part of
the boys because we all know when you're
on these these positions of leadership
you kind of separated from the what goes
on with the boys if you know what I mean
um but that's all I wanted was just to
be I feel like I belong
um and to film with the boys and then
what was your pathway post that post
that playing for the New Zealand skills
uh so actually me and CJ we had this
this plan brew and um
he was hating on on playing Arctic at
the time down at Mana oh yeah and um so
we're kind of organizing that he was
comfortable to the boys play ten I'd
play nine and would just rip [ __ ] up
um and do all these wonderful things
um however I think that's when he got
off with his contract with uh Wellington
and the cane
I'll get it on around that time was when
uh contracts started really kicking off
for schoolboys
um you know we're getting like the likes
of TJ and Sammy signing up with Super
Rugby it was quite a big thing at that
time uh this was back in 2009
and um yeah so I ended up um deciding to
leave school uh my attendance at school
was pretty poor I had UE level three so
I was just like I don't need to go to
class I'll just focus on Rugby in my
last year so I did that
um yeah so there was a bit of an
incentive uh for me turn up the class or
don't come back so uh
I don't go back
I ended up signing with waikato on a pu
contract there and they enrolled and
paid for my study I support an exercise
science
um things don't work out and study I
think I did one semester and I ended up
working for Graham Bowen who was the CEO
of white couple at the time um helping
honors
his uh horsepower
so this uh this kind of how things would
be
um play for hotapu awesome club
um full of support um Adam poker AKA
Venom was our coach at the time well we
had some great today we had um Sumo uh
Keith Lauren uh yeah so the team was was
packed uh so uh 5c
um me some old battles they're still
checking away in their late 30s um
brominee Graham was there too see us I
would have just just made the All Blacks
I think that year so um
yeah I've got a lot of a lot of starting
time their post office and then did you
join the Army at some point it must have
been around the same time was it yeah
yeah so um I kind of went through the
grades and wakato made
their comps and then made the patrol
team for the NZ under 20s
um and my opinion was the five by far
one of the greatest teams yeah I think
the 2010 and I I think that was the
first time when I went to that camp uh
that I had missed the timing uh it was a
stretching session in the morning at 7
30 and 9 seconds and and not once in my
career then as I ever did that yeah and
you know awesome we did an Outdoor
Pursuit Challenge and whatnot and then I
I returned back to White Castle
and I'll actually uh sat in front of
Chris Gibbs he called me into his office
and he said he just looked at me you
know he should be like this
rubbing his chin and he just had this
contract and he threw it in front of him
and he goes this is yours if you make
the engine under 20.
and um I just sat there and I was just
like
if you if this is all you want me for
then now you can get stuff you know I
felt like I wasn't appreciated at all
yeah but just because you know if I
missed out on the scene that I wasn't
good enough
you know so I kind of just thought nah
I'm sick of this all this this politics
in this game I'm done
though I just left um
I left Hamilton and went back to
Australia on on the old lady's couch
and um kind of went through a real boozy
boozy stage of my life where I was just
drowning my sorrows really and kind of
all my frustration and everything
um but yeah
that's kind of how that ended and um
back in 2008 I had applied for the
Indian army
and I thought oh I'll follow that up and
um yeah I met my now wife
uh wasn't wasn't long I think a month
into our relationship she fell pregnant
and then uh I was away on my basic
training five weeks and why do uh and I
left left to uh for the first
first answer can trimester
um hey that's crazy so Chris Gibbs you
get a contract from Chris Webbs you
didn't
feel appreciated and you're willing to
just walk away from
your rugby career pretty much was it at
the time were you thinking this is this
is almost me done I don't really care
about rugby anymore yeah pretty much man
and like reckon it in that space like I
had a lot going on like study was wasn't
helping at all you know but the five
five am wake up to go to the gym I know
everyone does it yeah but everyone's
different and it was taking a toll on me
um our flat uh probably wasn't the
healthiest environment either but yeah
just a lot of just life very life in
general
um you know a young 17 year old
uh leaving school into a flat studying
trying to pursue his rugby career all of
these compounding like pressures bro was
just too overwhelming for me and I just
I just bet the dummy and I and I know
that wasn't Chris's intent
um you know it was probably more of an
incentive for me to kind of Chase that
and and kind of use it as motivation to
to push myself mate we're only 17 at the
time that's still yeah I know
yeah oh 17 turning 18 so um yeah I was I
was young I was just a baby all right
and and then what you you spoke about
like the sort of drowning your Sorrows
what did that sort of look like
um as a 17 year old on your mum's couch
where well I actually threw that whole
year in 2010 bro I I had I made a bet
with um Ellen poker and uh that was to
not drink yeah so I've been pretty much
the majority of the whole year and I do
owe you a dinner uh Venom I'll get there
bro
that was there was a price you know if I
lost a bit I've taken some dinner and if
I did it then you'd take me to dinner
yeah
um but yes I went the majority of the
year
um alcohol free and I guess that stopped
me from socializing as well
um but when I did hit the drink oh man
um we all know about the shed by Tommy
and uh NASA yeah we had some good good
memories there in um yeah man I was just
at least Cannon it was it was not a not
a good time uh yeah so when you went
when you did drink was it just you
couldn't stop or
what did it actually look like couldn't
stop by I was kind of yeah yeah just
like didn't really
give two shits about anyone or anything
mostly I don't care about myself I guess
I was just going through a period of of
um
oh sorry and I don't know how to deal
with it
um so the best way was to spend it with
my family and just drink
um you know I I think or one at one
stage throughout Christmas the Christmas
period I don't remember being sober for
at least a week
it was just um day after day or probably
a week even even more
um we also drank every day how do you
get out of that like um because you you
do end up making the turbo somehow from
this little rut so how did you get out
of that yeah yeah so um long story short
I finished my training my wife and I
ended up in Palmerston North and Linton
there
um I started my core training as an
engineer in the Army finished setting on
completion
um one of my bosses Laurel Mooney Lilo
he he bowled up to me and he said oh
and I was standing there at attention I
said uh it's my major he said uh do you
know who Jason O'Halloran and I said uh
uh yep you see it all he wants to know
if you want a contract
and then I uh I cook but he said I said
oh no thank you and I walked away
you know you know he just took off and
he said oh get back over here so uh I
came back and he said
um you know he uh he told me that um
Aaron Smith has just made the All Blacks
and he's looking for a heartbeat
um and he started to go on about the
club and you know maybe half down
long story through it he said oh well
think about it and get back to me
um so that's exactly what I did I went
home and I spoke to my wife
um we just had our newborn baby and I
just said hey Mama
um boobs wants to know if I won a
contract and she just looked at me and
she she said uh
up to you Dad just don't be a good or
Shoulda Woulda and that was all she said
yeah and um so I I accepted that offer
yeah and what was it like going into the
environment
uh it was exciting it was really
exciting
um definitely something that I had or
wanted to make of course you know you're
gonna you make it I knew there was a
stepping stone
uh yeah that was 2012.
um saying we had to eat the whole head
we had Crosby in there we had uh all the
boys
um but it was really cool uh um getting
to play with like Junior tomatisama
um it was kind of like you know when
you're a Star Striker as a kid watching
all these players and you're like yeah
I'm playing now yeah um it was just real
humbling and it was kind of like a sense
of achievement and accomplishment and so
I just got stuck in yeah that year was
all about me taking that opportunity
um because there was one that I thought
had slipped through my fingers and and
at the same time balancing uh where
cloth as a soldier as well so that was
quite challenging and then you obviously
went pretty well um that yeah first
first crack in there because like you
mentioned at the start that was when you
gotta call into the Hurricanes as uh was
it a wider Squad sort of contract or
development contract yeah yeah there was
there was I sparked quite a bit of
interest
um I knew a couple of games that
potatoes were looking at me as well
um and then and that came to uh
concussion got got the better of me
um we'll talk a bit more about that but
um
yeah yeah so the canes uh alarm at the
time he said um I've got
I think we had about five pass back that
year eight yeah
um and all of them were injured
and so um he said oh I can't I kind of
need you
um do you want to come down on a wider
um just to help us out and whatever so
yeah I gladly accepted that and that's
how I got down there it was it was a bit
of a funny funny feeling like I wasn't
quite settled and and
I guess what had happened there um
whilst I was a part of the team or I
felt like I I wasn't
um
I don't know do you want to dive into
that so that's uh yeah let's go let's go
yeah I kind of like right from the
get-go hey
um you know the team was to assemble on
Sunday to have seen photos and all that
stuff and I kind of got there or you
just don't come five five yeah
um just turn off on Monday ready to go
um so I was just kind of like oh yeah so
it is you know here's me just a new beat
for the scene all good
um accommodation there was a whole
nother a whole nother kettle of fish
like I think our baby was about 10
months old at the time and um I think it
was me Callum Gibbs uh Zeke
um and who was the deal Butler from both
play
um mark evitt Mark Everett is another
great yeah you're one of the great
um yeah we ended up in the penthouse on
Tory Street for for about a week or two
and then we got ship shipped to another
apartment and then um my wife and I
ended up getting that apartment down I
promise tips oh yeah
um but yeah yeah so that was that was
really cool um but man 10 month old you
know we're getting thrashed six or
almost seven days of the week and all I
wanted to do was rest my wife at home
was just like I want to get out of here
you know so that he had that going on
the whole family Dynamic and trying to
achieve balance there you know I
couldn't sleep I was I was in a deep
depressive state
um just from all these like pressures
um you know I was still employed by the
Army uh still having to be a husband or
not a husband a fiance at the time a
father trying to juggle rugby in my
commitment to rugby
um
new environments all of these things so
I was quite under the pump I couldn't
sleep I was waking up probably eight to
ten times a night I ended up getting uh
prescription medications to help that
um I was having anxiety attacks panic
attacks before every training
um and I blamed it on the protein
because I I before then I never really
took protein so
um yeah just a whole lot of like a
roller coaster emotions barrier was just
crazy and then um like you said hey you
probably wouldn't have guessed that I
was in that state but and I was I was I
was probably the bottom of the pet
suicidal uh during that time true yeah
absolutely no idea uh for me looking at
you at the time coming in you always
like real energetic friendly sort of guy
and then to hear that's pretty crazy and
so what are those um panic attacks look
like like what what's that actually look
like heading to training and having a
panic attack
um you know bowling up to training is
kind of like a gulp you know here we go
again
um kind of you know all those those
feelings of self-doubt um fear of the
unknown
um kind of second guessing yourself not
knowing if you're good enough yeah um in
a new part of how I ended up there may
have contributed to that
um you know feeling kind of left out a
little bit all of those things you know
or kind of maybe questioning your very
software is to remind yourself with its
time you know so so what it'll feel like
is it you know get really booed up on
the genuine shed and start walking out
and I just felt like my heart and my
guts wanted to jump out of my throat
like just like real bad indigestion like
I want to dispute but nothing wanted to
come out it was like really gassy
yeah my heart rate heart rate was
elevated
um
yeah I just I just did not want to be
there and then as soon as we started in
those nerves all settled down
yeah and then you go and storm into
Davey Gray's office and blame the
protein
I know I don't know you know nutrition
was quite a big thing at the time I
think we're burning through about well
over three and a half thousand calories
a day and
um yeah but it was quite easy to pick on
protein because that's the only thing
that that I changed in my in my diet
yeah
um well you know I think back to to that
time as well I'm sitting in the changing
room and I actually
I resonated a lot with Ray Lilo
um you know because he's a he's another
Legend and I I actually have a lot of
time for Ray the razor he was an awesome
bloke and he was quite open and cheering
with how he felt um so we used to have
these little little secret discussions
with each other you know kind of talking
about how we feel
um and and you know just supporting each
other uh he had always read my lunchbox
no but messed a mess of love and um yeah
really really grateful for his support
during that song maybe there is so much
pressure on especially those pre-seasons
are so tough eh like you say it was sort
of six days of brutal brutal training
and then trying to balance the the
Family Life man it is it's a bloody hard
job eh absolutely bro and like you know
there's so much support there and yes I
guess people would feel like they don't
they're not supported
and I guess it's not so much in the
space of having
um you need this here take that kind of
like more more mentally
um and I guess from a holistic approach
to to well-being
um yeah because because how do you help
someone who can't really explain what
they're going through when it's new to
them yeah you're not gonna you're not
really gonna ask for help are you
because you don't even know what how it
looks like or or what can help you
um but yeah definitely navigating that
in a mental space
um psychologically was was probably the
overarching challenge uh during that
time and you mentioned Suicidal Thoughts
like how often were you having those
sort of thoughts
um
yeah I've traced back through in the
first time I thought about suicide was
actually when I was 12.
um you know so so and that's probably
earlier I I haven't quite dive deep
enough like 12 is definitely as a
courtyard I was thinking of suicide then
and actually it became a place of
comfort for me
um like I knew I'd never ever take my
life but suicide became my mate but
became my buddy because it understood
how I felt um
yeah so every time I was quite happy to
go to those dark spaces because I knew I
knew how to navigate it you know I could
sit there quite happily in a doctor
Christmas plate but the most unfortunate
thing was how it affected my family and
others because I just permeated their
Darkness
and you know unknowingly and and not
because I wanted to but because that's
where I found solace the the scary part
for me was actually
addressing the issues as to why I'd get
for those states that was the scary part
that's what scared the [ __ ] out of me so
yeah I was quite familiar bro so it was
there was no like this was a first-time
thing that was my my place of my Safe
Haven
and it's pretty scary like uh I actually
was at a dinner the other night with
Mike King who was speaking about how
many kids have Suicidal Thoughts coming
through school and all the stats around
the New Zealand
um suicide rates man it's it's pretty
scary when you look at it like how
common it is and how little was being
done about it absolutely bro and um
that's not putting blame on anyone but I
guess that's the environment that our
children are raised in that we have a
lot of people a lot of parents
um including myself because I've walked
through that too that have a lot of
trauma and underlying issues that they
fail to to address
and and I guess you you think about when
your child going back to who's your
biggest influence in your life that's
your mum and dad you know they they
pretty much instill the values that they
have into you
um and some of those values uh can be uh
I guess Negative they they don't serve
you in a positive way
um it's not only until you're an adult
we start to question these things and I
guess ask the questions why or why do I
react this way why am I triggered um why
am I abusive why do I talk to alcohol
all the time and um quite often you can
look back to the way you erase
um and and there's a lot of answers
there same again like I said before
um all of these things that you
experience as a child because you don't
know how to express it or you're told or
don't cry boy hard enough they become a
part of who you are as an adult so what
was your Escape in while you're at the
canes were you hitting the booze or what
yeah what were you up to how are you
coping with it all uh so my Escape was
actually the thief
um yeah I'd go diving I'd take my family
diving with me that was that was the
only place that I could go to
um to feel like a small fish in the
Ponder game to feel like the weight of
the world is lifted
um you know just straight back took me
back to my connection with with the tile
with with nature to be at one was
everything to close off the noise
um the font piece peace and serenity in
my mind through being
um I guess just a small part of
something greater
um and then at the same time a bonus was
getting a code for my funny uh which my
my wife and my daughter enjoyed a lot of
power but a crayfish
um always went down well
yeah oh so your pathway from the Keynes
you're back to the turbos and I get I'm
guessing this one is pretty uh bad run
of injury start yeah yeah and I guess
that was because during my time spent at
the cane
um I had
Connor planted the seed that I didn't
want to play rugby anymore yeah
um you know I didn't want to be just
this wasn't the environment that I
wanted to surround myself and full of
ego
um full of uh I guess backstabbing in a
way you know makes that who you thought
were your mates
um make the starting 15 and then you'll
you become a no one
um you know you get injured and then you
kind of fall off the wagon and no one
really cares about you anymore yeah so
that's that's kind of I was just like oh
another thing he just doesn't speak to
me
um and then it's probably because I
couldn't stand up my own truth
um you know I couldn't Express who I was
um because I was in the in the mindset
of self-doubt and all those things
um now I'd love to be put back in that
environment I I thrive I understand my
position then how to navigate that fine
um but he ended up back back in
Palmerston North and there you're right
that's when all my injuries came uh
that's my ACL
um I fractured my orbital wall I've got
three plates on my face now uh I ended
up doing a thin osmosis in my right
ankles they rip the ligaments that hold
my tip and flip apart
oh this goes on bro and concussion was
probably the biggest biggest issue hands
down concussion when did the concussion
start oh same again bro concussion
started from a really young age through
high school yeah but by the time I left
High School I probably had about a dozen
concussions to my name
uh I remember one game uh playing
against Hamilton boys uh away
and I got knocked out twice in that game
because even it wasn't even recorded on
video
um or because I wanted to make New
Zealand schools and I remember the game
before that
uh I'm sorry two games before they all
got concussed and I made an active
decision to to stand out of the next
game before the Hamilton game so that I
can recover for it um but that means I'd
missed out on my 50th game for
um
Jersey it's like yeah yeah so concussion
bro walked out a out of high school with
concussion again concussions in Hamilton
and Club rugby
and then stepping into uh
semi-professional professional rugby
where things are a lot faster uh people
are a lot stronger quicker the unpacks
is greater
um and then the halfback that I was the
one who likes dark spaces and those
rocks
um yeah my head's got a bit of a
thrashing
um I remember one game
getting Alberta in the in the trend by
player and uh this was the
against counties and uh one of my eyes
was normal and the other the ground
level was right up
um so I went in for the shed at half
time saying um you know this is what's
happening
uh I don't think I can continue and then
just be nice and I know I can say this
um and there's no again no blame or or
presents against
um the coaching staff at the time
um but they just asked me if I could
give it three more minutes and um you
know I could have said no but I said
yeah yeah I can do that
feel to jump back on the field bro bait
and cool was a kicker I couldn't see any
one of their faces from standing we all
wanted half back
it encourages pop the stump off of a
restart on me bro and it just went
straight through the red basket and I
was just like no get off the field
um I've had pre-season games and and
seasoned games where I've taken blows
and my head just got like I wanted to
explode
um and my last in 2015 was the Steamers
uh yeah just the just a full contact
training got tackled uh landed on my
side my head hit the ground like so and
same thing immediately my head just felt
like I wanted to explode
um that's when I kind of thought [ __ ]
I'll get a take a look at this and take
things a bit more seriously
concussion is such a scary thing hey
like um far out that's that's a pretty
brutal concussionist dude were you aware
of the risks going back on the field
like as a young Philly we were the risks
what was it associated with concussion
um the education was there but I guess
you know as a rugby player trying to
trying to crack it yeah now you'll do
whatever it takes you'll do whatever it
takes so you know we can blame nzru for
whatever processes and stuff that
they're putting in place but us also as
players we we need to be accountable and
be responsible for actually saying nah
I'm not all right and I and I truly
value my health and well-being so I'm
gonna make the decision not to go back
on the field we can't just leave it all
in the hands of things that I eat to say
well your concussion tests are failing
us because I get concussion I still pass
them you know that's that's rubbish
um we we also need to take
responsibility of our own health
um so you say yes it's not there's no
one to blame I guess it's just um
understanding that both of us play
um crucial Parts in making those
decisions
um but we try and do our best to support
each other and how we can best manage
that 100 mate you see it all the time
and I I know it's improved a lot since
probably back when uh you were taking
these knocks but
um I still don't think we're there yet
there's still a lot of guys who I know
um can you can beat the system if you
want to I mean a lot of the questions
are how are you feeling how's your head
are you feeling normal and if you're
saying yes to all of those but you're
not feeling right you're obviously um
you're just cheating yourself at the end
of the day isn't it because it is your
head but your head you I mean your
memory and stuff you seem like still
right on with all of that haven't got
any side effects from concussion now ah
yeah that's that's kind of a well I
don't know what are the long-term
effects you know I battled uh quite a
long time uh with short-term effects you
know like sensitivity for life real
sensitive to loud sounds and and all the
rest of it you know migraines and
headaches all all of the symptoms that
actually took a long time even my mood
you know was that part of the reason why
why I'd go into the the states of
depression you know my wife often
challenged me like you know at your head
you know
um all these concussions is taking a
toll on you I'm sick of this you know
she she coughed a lot bro
um
a short load from me
um but yeah
it was it was it was kind of kind of
hard at some point how concussion has
affected me or continues to affect me
because I guess we haven't reached that
stage yet so what's important is that I
actually made a decision to stop
because I found that it was taking less
um less of a blow for me to fill uh
rocks or get a little bit tipsy
um so yeah
you know because there's a player bro
when you put all your eggs in in one
basket trying to crack it as a rugby
player
um that's all you're focused on yeah so
I mean you are gonna lie and I put my
hand up now and say that I like many
times and that's probably why it is
insufficient
um data or history medically to support
my application uh to the benevolent
welfare fund
um but that's also understanding that
kind of like the you either make it or
break break it type thing so of course
you're going to do whatever it takes to
put yourself in a in the best position
to to make the teams to get exposure
um so yeah so talk talk to me about that
fund that you mentioned there like what
what is that fund and what do you have
to do to
um receive money from that fund um
firstly bring your stuff was saying um
for me applying for this fund was never
ever about money it was um kind of to
highlight uh what I see or some of the
commonalities or common issues shared
amongst players
um regarding player wealthy
um because I sure as hell they want
anyone to go through the same Journey or
pathway that I have through rugby it's
to a point where I don't even encourage
my nephew the winner of my financial
place because I just don't know
um of the the safety for the safety is
Paramount really
um but so it does welfare fund um is
established by the NZ RPA The Players
Association for players who are
contracted
I think there's many different reasons
you can apply for it but in my case it's
for a career ending injury uh which can
be resolved through concussion or any
other injury um but yeah so so I
actually never wanted to apply for this
um it was I took the ABS out white
beating a couple years back
and I'm very invited me for dinner and
yeah yeah they they I got got chatting
and caught up before the boys and it was
two Sams Sammy Kane said me whitelock it
kind of concussion jumped into them and
then I mentioned about Mike and cash and
they were like nah bro you gotta apply
for this you're you're a contractor
you're you're entitled for
the support that you received was wasn't
the flashes and and
um yeah you you definitely deserve it
and I kind of [ __ ] still I was like oh
it's not about the money you know I'm
we're quite happy we have everything
that we we need in our lives at the
moment
and then they kind of ham at home about
well what about everyone else
you know what what about everyone else
that are going through a similar
position or don't know don't have a
voice
um they don't know how to navigate the
space and just give up
um what about the change for the system
to to prevent this from happening in
future cases so that's that's kind of my
reason behind
um behind applying
because I guess either way our
presidents will be sick it's quite clear
and I know um
there's a lot of rugby players out there
that would support I guess my view and
take on this and how's the application
going
um it's it's we all know it's quite a
slow in arduous task uh there's a bit of
a process to I guess putting your your
case forward
um
and and yeah Rambo uh Mark Granby
absolute Legend he's been um
one of one of a guy a hell of a guy
helping me through that process even
just as a sounding board and kind of
um resonating with what a lot of um of
recorded or that I have to see
um he also supported and agreed um we've
managed to come up with a few ideas as
well to kind of
um help negate or address some of these
issues
um one in particular was around the
medical documentation of rugby players
one of my concerns was like why is it
that until you make a semi-professional
professional level that your health
becomes relevant now what about your
your career as a jab player as a high
school player you could have received x
amount of concussions throughout their
period but it only becomes relevant when
you become professional
and part of that too is that every team
has a team doctor and those team doctors
change all the time so all your medical
history and your records just bounce
around with different practices with
different doctors
um there's it's not centrally located
where we can just go uh NZ are you I
need my medical history please they pull
up the file and there'll be your history
it's not that easy I found myself
jumping around between eight different
doctors trying to trying to get some
some evidence so yeah you know we we
thought well how can we
what's what's the solution a simple
installation perhaps the population
and it was something simple like
carrying a diary like you know like a
farmer will have a notebook and you
write down everything that happens on
the farm
same thing happens with the rugby player
you note down every concussion every
injury that you have is a is a written
record of what you've experienced
because we can't rely on the system at
the moment so what's like I mean the
diary is the solution when did when do
guys start implementing that
I want to encourage every rugby player
to start now yeah and and kind of just
use it as a dump to dump every injury
that you can think of into your book
and then moving forward just the note
down how your day was or you know and
it's good just for reflection too to
start creating awareness of how you
actually feel what's going on in in the
uh the top two here
um but it's just a good way to protect
yourself essentially because you might
find yourself in this position I never
thought I'd end up in this position
where my career would end
um so yeah it's just something that'll
help protect you if that's on um comes
up yeah and getting back to when your
career ended like what was the deciding
factor for you to end your career I
guess was it a hard decision for you to
walk away from the game I know you
weren't really enjoying it you didn't
feel like it was for you
um but what was the like medical
reasoning behind the exit of the game I
guess so I I had to see a neurologist Dr
Peter right in Cambridge
um and we did all the necessary scan
yeah and so I went over there to meet up
with them and we kind of discussed my
history of rugby and and how many
concussions I had and how I uh the
symptoms so on and so forth uh anyway we
kind of had like a
uh how would you describe it just a
casual conversation around what this
could potentially mean for me and he
presented me with the with the story of
a two-sided coin
um and he said uh yeah you can flop the
coin our heads you walk out of my office
and you have a successful career you
play
um hundreds and hundreds of games and
and be fine uh the other side of the
coin is that you walk out of maltest
take bomb or head knock in your cabbage
for the rest of your life
and um that really happened with me
because my wife and I had had plenty of
these discussions and she said I won't
be wiping your ass
you know kind of you know provoking me
to to think deep and hard about about
this because it was serious and um I
just hit them on the spot where
um that's enough for me I'll make my
mind up I'm done I'll finish right here
right now
and um unfortunately I felt like that
conversation was a bit off the cards and
it was reflected in this report because
it was never ever stated in me
which kind of leads me from my second
Point around the support that we
received in these really important
appointments
um you know after speaking to Rainbow he
said oh you probably could have got a
second second opinion
well I never knew that I had no one
there supporting me
um you know would have been good to have
a union rifty because an important
decision was made right there on the
spot
um had I known there was a second
opinion to be made or to be had or would
have taken it because I I could have had
opportunity to put um to take my whanau
overseas and kind of live out my golden
years and rugby toxins yes I did a
opportunity must but um what's the
opportunity again
um through helping others so they don't
make this mistake too 100 so did you
were you just going to these
appointments by yourself and you just
made that decision purely on yourself
and then it was done yeah well a lot of
the thinking and the deep thought
happened prior to to all of us you know
I knew my head had taken a beating
throughout my career yeah
um and
to actually you know from how how that
last concussion played up was that I
actually didn't take a direct head knock
but yeah my head wanted to blow up yeah
you know so you alarm Bells start
ringing you know you start thinking oh
[ __ ] what's this going to mean
um you know the amount of force needed
to trigger symptoms and stuff was
getting less and less
[Music]
um so I mean that goes back to why are
players put in a position
um where they're juggling their their
life or their career
you know there's nothing for him to say
that I could have continues
apart from myself knowing that I I
shouldn't
okay so so ultimately players are being
left to juggle with their own life and
their well-being later like post rugby
um we always see it throughout my Rugby
um or these old betlers that have played
you know they're popping pills all these
props they're popping films to stay on
the field yeah you know what about when
they stop rugby what's going to happen
then you're obviously not going to be as
mobile as you were you're not going to
be involved in all this training and
that is a mental battle there alone yeah
so so what happened
yeah it's massive because obviously and
the later you play a lot of these guys
are getting paid massive money fear of
uh the unknown of post footy
um it's easier to just keep going and
keep providing for the family and do
whatever it takes like you say if it
means taking seven anti-inflammatories a
day then uh that's what that's what
they'll do yeah yeah it's just kind of
like all I've got a symptom here or
here's a pill that will look after you
yeah I'll take care of it you know so
you can keep playing yeah see you man
that's a tricky one
um but you know there's there's a
you know because Rugby's been your loss
for for some quite a substantial amount
of time
um so so when you called you go cold
turkey and you cut yourself from rugby
from playing especially
your whole life changes though it's just
like well you think you still have to be
this this athlete this high-level
athlete and you maintain your body to
Peak Peak physical condition you know
you're still thrashing yourself in the
cardio space you're still pumping tin
um and you're still eating really well
um for me it took me like about six
years six seven years to finally
understand that I didn't need to be a
Peak Performance athlete anymore you
know so now so now all I do bro is Yoga
in a walk yeah
yeah but beforehand I thought I had to
do CrossFit and like really elevate my
heart heart rates and do all these
things be strong and I was just like for
what what am I doing there for I I don't
have to perform anymore
and how long was your obviously from
that last knock how long was it before
you felt that you were fully sweet again
ah
um but yeah probably I don't know maybe
about a year a year and a half after
that yeah
um yeah and I guess that's kind of just
just working through what actually
happened what unfolded
um and and
was that the right decision you know
that I go about it the right way
um all of these things it's not so much
just specifically about the head knock
itself
there's everything else that comes with
it you know like
um say just a holistic approach to that
whole event
what does that mean for my body it meant
that I couldn't exercise on a regular
because symptoms would pop up
so what did that mean moving forward
what does my my uh exercise look like in
um you know what about the food if I'm
not exercising I'm still chowing down a
lot of food I'm going to blow out
okay what about mentally what how does
that affect you mentally not being able
to exude energy and stuff now how do I
find ways to exit
um what I can't
do through exercise
um yeah so so I wouldn't say it was
specifically about the head knocking
being right I think it was just
everything all of the above
um to bring me to a point of
understanding and being able to step
back and go well that was a tough time
you did well or you didn't you could do
this better you know
and did you miss did you miss rugby or
like how long since you were out of the
game Did you sort of think far I I do
miss it or did you never never really
got to the point where you missed
playing the game yeah I I
um it often pops into mine like I just
miss being with the boys yeah throwing
the ball around you know all of that
that's good fun just everything about it
you know it was a game that I really
loved playing
yeah I I actually turned off the TV I
I'd been watching I probably still don't
watch a lot of rugby today
um when someone gets a big hard-on about
the All Blacks and watching all blacks
I'm just like oh cool bro I'll just
crack on
um I I just probably just prefer to
watch the Highlight yeah and um yeah
just silently support the boys but yeah
you know rugby took up so much of my
life but I'd hate to let it
um continue to do that
um doesn't mean I won't watch rugby but
um there's a lot more time that I'd like
to dedicate to my family and other
things to my whanau hapu andui
um as opposed to
giving up uh three or four days of the
week coaching yeah um and rugby
and even watching it you sort of sound
like you've gone on a bit of a spiritual
journey post footy as well so how did
that start and
um what was the sort of reasoning behind
that
yeah well we're going to take a bit of a
deep dive here then if you're gonna
touch on spirituality but uh yeah man
um so so we kind of got to a point in
our lives and this was not long enough
uh the first covered lockdown and
um things kind of had a boiling point
you know I was working uh full-time or
shift work as a career firefighter my
wife was working uh full-time 40 hours a
week staying home looking after the kids
um and then yeah uh a breakdown happened
and and from that it kind of triggered a
bit of a
a bit of a Snowball Effect into what is
it exactly that we want in our lives and
um everything that was happening in our
lives kind of wasn't a part of it
and what we did want
um we could make it happen now or at the
time
um so we've done that but what actually
kind of triggered
um me to look Within Myself and talk
myself out was um I sat on the couch one
night
um glazed out of my Dome [ __ ] I've
never been into drugs or anything I was
kind of like the Curious kid on me kind
of going why does everyone get addicted
to this um Sarah you know this was me
just finding up and um I sat there
blazed out of my Dome and sitting next
to me was my two girls
and I looked at them and I just
I was hit with what they exact what they
wanted from me like exactly what they
wanted from me and it was well un
unconditional love and attention
undivided attention and I was just like
whoa bro and I just said to myself bro
you need to sort your [ __ ] out you need
to get on top of yourself you need to do
everything that you've been running away
from
um and and and I don't wanna have to be
under the influence of anything to be
able to feel what I just felt because I
I I was staying cold bro honestly my
emotions were absent I I didn't even
know what feeling was I was so
cold-hearted it wasn't funny yeah I lost
my kids and my family but not in a way
that I can express for them now now I'm
quite open I can cry I can be vulnerable
um yeah so so that's kind of what
triggered my journey through and
um a lot has happened since and what
does that Journey look like how do you
how do you get into that like
uh yeah I'll say uh
my wife and I are kind of setting up a
charitable trust now that that is
entering uh the healing space there's no
hard and fast kind of like this is how
you get there it is a journey and it's a
journey to self-discovery
um Connor
yeah doing all the hard work diving deep
within everything starts with self bro
and um you have to
gonna take a look at what shapes you
what makes you and make choices as to
whether or not you you agree or or that
serves you
um so we're through all the trauma and
all the the hurts and all of those
things
um that you have to to kind of step into
you to find your true self and your your
expression
um to find your individuality your
uniqueness uh to and sustain in your
truth unconditionally being you
um and and and the service of others
yeah
and is that sort of what you're doing
now is that where you're looking to take
uh work at the moment is it down that
sort of road yeah yeah it is down that
road bro and um I guess my wife and I
have both worked really hard over the
last oh I'm going to say our lifetime
yeah because everything that happened
need has happened
um was now we've now reached this uh I
guess a space where we understand our
higher purpose and and we're working to
achieve it
um and that's definitely in the service
of others so reaching out to people or
people reaching up to us to find the
tools and the knowledge that they need
to be able to deal with uh whatever's
going on in their lives
um and it's definitely a holistic
approach
um there's no one way to attack it and
it is designed by you because ultimately
You Are the Healer
um we can't tell you how to do that you
will know it's just our job to kind of
like bring the light uh to shine you
back on the past that you've forgotten
um so yeah that's a full intuitively LED
there's many uh
facets that make up knowing but uh yeah
my wife and I are working hard to try
and put together something that's
palatable and digestible for people to
understand because it is a journey very
and it's a long journey it's a lifetime
and I guess instead of looking towards
something to buy for uh we're both on
something to live for love that right
that's powerful stuff eh that's um yeah
that's cool bro that's really cool and
um I like at one stage in my life I
never ever thought I'd find uh this the
space of Enlightenment
um
but but it is cool and and a beautiful
effects of it and it's all about
focusing on myself bro and I know it
sounds selfish the most but it's
actually not
because when you are when you're [ __ ]
focusing on yourself and doing the hard
work for yourself to be the better you
the best you that you can be
that's only uh a byproduct that it
Ripples and flows on to the lives of
those around you your whanau friends and
and Beyond
much like what you're doing Jimmy you're
you're touching the heart of many many
players by sharing sharing uh stories
and Journeys with other rugby players
because no doubt people will resonate
with certain things and everyone's
experiences and I guess that's all we
can can speak from his own love to
experience anything beyond that you're
kind of like
well I'm sure there's a lot of a lot of
players or people who are listening to
this and can resonate with this and some
of this stuff it's been a pretty special
hour so far but I do have some questions
that I did check up on Instagram that
have come in for you so we'll get
through a few of these before we finish
and the first one
um is it true that you don't ever shop
at a supermarket yeah uh yeah so quite
recently bro
um an article came out
um about my time spent foraging so I
went three months uh only living or
uh what I could grow together uh dive
hunt fish
um all right there were no condiments so
no sauces no nothing all I had was salt
so for the majority of the time I either
ate a broil steamed or boiled
um and then you know I'd get uh a bit of
wild pocket I'll render it down and then
I had something for Brian so that's when
Brian come back and
um and then the article yeah so so a
friend of mine um she wanted to do an
article on it and um you know how the
media Works bro they kind of contort
things and you know make it make it
attractive to the general public and so
the the I guess the title that that was
there I had a baby cleanly father threes
or supermarkets or something or other
and um that was definitely
um not out of my mouth yeah
um so it was good that I had an
opportunity to speak I had an interview
with jono and Ben on the hits
um to kind of talked to that too and
then uh interview with Jenny Mae
Clarkson on breakfast one morning
um but yeah no I I still shop at a
supermarket and but what I do lead is a
life of plant-based and seafood yeah
it's not pescatarian pescatarian still
allows uh dairy products and poultry
so yeah majority plant-based and Seafood
um yeah and and I I guess there will be
a stage where we will
um probably leave the supermarket behind
and probably rolls into another Journey
or copper that we have going we'll start
Food Forest design food sovereignty
um and and our nursing and reclaiming
the knowledge and whatnot that we have
down here on the coast you if you have
been following my socials you would have
seen that I put in a food Frost system
here with a lot of tropical fruits
papaya cherimoya adamoya berries you've
got blueberries sugar cane
um yeah
but um yeah I hope to bring my family
along this one because it's quite easy
for me to live without the supermarket
but in reality it's a slow transition
you know we're undoing generations and
generations of relying on supermarkets
and stuff
but yeah yeah I'd like to bring my
family along this time so in order for
us to not be reliant on supermarkets we
have to first uh setup systems here at
home they provide food for food for us
throughout the year so you mentioned
there that it was relatively easy for
you
um what sort of time does it take to
make sure that yeah you know you've got
enough food to sort of live off like
you're obviously out fishing hunting or
gathering a fair bit I'm I guess the
ease of supermarkets what sort of makes
it so tempting for everyone else
um well the main reason for me was well
why why I did go down there class was
what I inject yeah you know controlling
what I did and and Supermarket Foods you
have all these preservatives and who
knows chemicals used to grow the veggies
and whatnot you can't control that you
don't know what's going into your body
and it truly is a matter of what you
ingest is pretty much what makes you up
you know so so they're not not only
limit you to what you eat but what you
hear what you see what you smell you can
think of all the senses who you surround
you with on social media
all of that all of that stuff is is what
you ingest what you're taking in
um so you're only going to reflect that
as well
um back to your question yeah yeah it
does take a lot of time it does take a
lot of time but I actually I've made the
decision just like that I just said to
my wife I'm going I'm doing this from
now so I had done no preparation
whatsoever
and I guess let's let's kind of kind of
reaches into your ability or the type of
person you are because a lot of my
community here my partners were more
than happy to help me and and to say I
did this on my own would be a joke
because that was definitely not the case
I was well supported by my whanau and
friends
um you know they enabled me to to share
what I had on offer which was fish and
whatnot and in return they'd give me
fruits and vegetables that they grow and
their own homes
immerse myself I immersed myself within
the environment you know with the neuro
here uh where we live I found uh banana
plantations of um tropical fruits like
our fruit trees
um I've found Puja Watercress all of
those things but that was just by me
connecting with the pile by getting out
there so in terms of what what does it
cost it's actually expensive and and in
relation to time but not money yeah and
and we often hear the the same time as
money well
when you when you can't understand that
then you know the importance or the the
cost of what it is yeah so I haven't
been working for probably I don't know
how long I've I finished up as a
firefighter in August uh 13th of August
last year yeah
since then I haven't been working I've
just been putting time into one getting
myself right first so that I can help
others and then kind of all these
different code proper now popped up to
help support that very cool very cool I
love that uh makes me want to live off
the land for a couple of months see okay
although I'm a terrible Hunter terrible
fisherman but uh could probably grow up
veggie garden oh it's the end of this
boat it's as simple as that as just
starting you know because
um
by planting one vegetable or one crop
you'll then learn to grow others you
know
um or you can just go Dive Right In but
I wouldn't encourage that
only if you're in the position for DC
yeah but there's a lot of people out
there there's a lot of resources to help
you
um but yeah very cool okay next question
how far does he think he could have gone
with no injuries it's worth no injuries
um definitely the blacks yeah I I
definitely see myself in the black team
yeah um yeah I often think too and I
know that when everyone would go around
the room and kind of ask for your
aspirations and stuff like that you know
the words are to be an all blacks was
thrown around quite commonly yeah
they're nice to say it just to kind of
appease the room I actually didn't want
to be an all black I wanted to be a
jockey and when the Melbourne cups
you know so I was never never an
aspiration of mine but I felt like I see
appease people yeah so so again uh
accommodating the opinions of others
um and not stepping into my truth and
saying well actually they want to be a
rugby player I just want to enjoy their
journey and and whatever that looks like
it is so so probably that would have
habituated because I would have been
um just enjoying myself in general yeah
but definitely babies ah but
[Laughter]
right that is cool love that love that
mindset okay next question uh this this
is from our major sponsor swish uh if
you could get a video shout out from any
celebrity who would it be and why I
don't know I don't know that's a tough
question I'm yeah my celebrities would
probably be my bunny yeah
um you know uh for them to express their
love and and thankfulness to me means
far more than any other celebrity could
give so yeah so so my family that is
cool okay next one how does rugby
prevent the concussion issue in the game
sort of touched on this one
yeah concussion I mean this is a bit of
a rabbit hole here Jimmy you know we we
both know this uh the NZ are you
um the NZ RPA are actively working to
find Solutions and and halfways in which
to highlighting I guess look after our
players in that space
um because it is one where we know and I
remember looking back to Brad Weber when
he took that concussion in the game
bandel was horrific
and he ran out of the tunnel back onto
the field I was just like no way should
you be on that field yeah
um and then again I can't help I go back
to uh it has to be a relationship
between players and the union
um and and players actually just being
honest with themselves
um but I think that Honesty comes with
actually finding out what it is they
want in life
and understanding um that rugby rugby is
only a small portion of their life
um and and I guess that would help them
to make the better decisions around when
it comes to to concussions and actually
removing yourself from through the
through the injury but yeah I guess
education is key yeah uh how we go about
that education is another another
probably question to ask
um I guess things like this like this
podcast and sharing my experience about
concussion and what it means meant for
me
um would help
um and and I've reached out to you
things at IU as well and said that I'd
be glad to to talk about my experience
for concussion they had a few campaigns
running
um that never never eventuated
um sweet as moth is still still on on
the books
um but yeah I I
probably say that we need to take a leaf
out of women's rugby
um you know like the rugby that I see
woman play compared to men is one full
of love and passion you know we know
they get paid peanuts for for what they
do
um you know and it's reflected in the
style of rugby they play and I have to
give a big big me a big up to our our
woman in rugby
um I I think they've caused a pathway of
that that needs to be troubled you know
they interrugby
um after being qualified teachers
physios uh policewoman uh so on and so
forth with all these like massive
professions outside of rugby you know
their life is sorted if rugby was the
finish for them that'd be totally fine
you know they've got something on on
Beyond rugby
so
I mean too often players from a young
age it's even in schools you know rugby
Academy this is touching players are
almost a fail
because we know that not everyone cracks
it on Rugby and and and when you make it
you're not necessarily going to make it
when you're 18 or 17 it could happen
right up until you're in your 30s you
know so so that time is different for
for others it could be a matter of
someone getting injured
um but yeah definitely the way forward
is through women's rugby and and you
know the the paid disparity that they
battle with
um definitely needs to be addressed
because I see
um real real power and and a real
Guiding Light than one woman drunk
before men yeah well there's been big
shifts there I guess with I guess now
being televised all the
um local NPC competition women's game um
televised all their games obviously the
black ferns World Cup is going to be
hosted here in New Zealand all these
things I feel like the women's game is
growing like you say massively
absolutely brilliant they are great
examples of the game and as people in
general they are really lovely people
you know the the Sarah gosses or Sarah
hedones
um your Ruby tuis and and so on and so
forth there they are just amazing people
um but yeah yeah you know that's that's
just my thoughts anyway mate that's what
it's all about oh I've spoken through
season players that have like that have
had the high you know the fame and the
riches of rugby kind of coming towards
the end of their careers saying I'm
scared I don't know what to do you know
and these These are players that are
well known they're they're common
household names
and I think it's I think it's almost
everyone I think it's almost every
player who starts off their rugby career
early it's uh pretty intimidating going
to the end of it and not knowing what
you're going to do next yeah yeah you're
broke for sure and like yeah you know
because Rugby's been all you know and
then you know when you encounter a lot
of money then you hand it on to someone
who knows how to deal with money and you
just click the plane playing rugby you
know a lot of a lot of people like um I
really enjoyed snakey and and some Basin
yeah they were awesome people brand new
they're good examples for me real humble
you know had the head screwed on they
had a plan
um even CJ you know coming through the
ranks
um doing his study and making the Colts
back at the back in that day and then
kind of entering professional rugby
those were were people that I looked up
to yeah absolutely there's those three
no yeah okay last question I know you've
given heaps of advice throughout this
podcast already but probably the most
ever to be fair this is this has been
good but the best piece of advice you
have for a woodland listener hit me I
mean
we all know what we want in life or
although some people are a bit confused
that you can get confused at times but
um yeah don't don't settle for less man
like you you know what you're worthless
um and and don't let anyone tell you
that you know oh you're only worth this
much
um yeah yeah I guess then find yourself
and stand on that um and that'll take
you a long way had I done that when I
was you know Becca back as a little 17
year old things may have may have been
different
um but just uh definitely you have to
enjoy the journey
um gonna we know whether it's positive
or negative step back and appreciate uh
what learning is on offer
um that'll that'll do you a great deal
moving forward
um but yeah oh don't be scared to reach
out as well help us always
um available when you ask and um don't
be scared to put yourself in in the
state of vulnerability we we are sharing
your Deep Emotions because that's I
guess that's the true help that you that
you want and you're not going to get it
unless you are
not one piece of advice I think we've
got about four or five pieces of advices
there we are lucky you are lucky
listeners to being able to get that
Priceless piece of advice in there from
Papa photo one of the absolute great
Lads been a been a pleasure having you
on the podcast mate I I know once you
reached out on you um you would have had
plenty to talk about and there's some
real good discussion there
um some really good stuff around
concussion your purpose all these sort
of things it's uh it was a really cool
yarn so really appreciate you coming on
the podcast bro I wish you all the best
with whatever's next in your journey
thank you Jimmy and uh I'd like to thank
the Santa to show my gratitude and
thanks towards you bro um the money that
you're doing the space is awesome to
hear stories the different stories of
all our brothers playing rugby
um it's just amazing you know it
definitely resonates with a lot of
people I've watched a few of them and
yep that definitely touched me
um yeah but I'd also like to take this
opportunity to
I guess reach out for support
um with my application
um I know people may have found
themselves in a similar position for me
where I've got a good case but I'm
lacking evidence
um so if you're wanting to support this
course because it's not just it's about
me it's about the future of Road repair
and also those uh in the past who have
kind of felt their voices was turned on
diffuse
um so yeah
um happy to talk and and to discuss uh
what that looked like for you and then
I'm happy to to be your voice at the
table when the time comes how do people
um how do people get in touch how do
people uh show their support or get in
touch with you uh reach out on my
socials uh Facebook or Instagram uh we
can send me an email uh maybe you could
check a link my email on on the link I
will do that um
on my socials uh but yeah absolutely I
appreciate man all good bro thank you
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]